Let us build on this metaphor of periodic table a little bit further.
So earlier we came across another method of dealing with classification,
which we call top down or establish define.
In that method we had this classification hierarchy which start with a concept,
will establish it, then refine it, and refine it further if needed.
That particular control of processing is very well suited for
one kind of organization of concepts. It's very well suited for
one set of situations where we know something is already a vertebrate,
we're trying to establish whether it's a bird or a bluebird. And a different
kind of classification task. A better control of processing is to go bottom up.
Let's look at this a little bit more carefully. Here are a number of leaf nodes.
And we know, the agent knows something about the value for
each of these leaf nodes. And the task is to make a prediction at the root node.
So in this particular case imagine the task of the AA agent is to
predict the of the Dow Jones Industrial Average tomorrow. It'll be great to
have an AA agent like that. If we had a good AA agent like that, you and
I could both become very rich. Now how could this A,
agent make a prediction about the Dow Jones Industrial Average tomorrow?
Well, one way in which it could do it is it could look at the.
Information it has about the GDP the inflation and
employment today. but how does it know about the value GDP or the inflation or
employment today. Well it can look then at the values of the overtime hours.
The consumer sentiment index, new orders index and so on and so forth.
Now, the processing is largely, bottom up. We know something about the values or
the features that go into this concept.
And they're going to this concept, they're going to this concept.
You can abstract them and find the value of the GDP. And similarly for this, and
then abstract it further. So the control of processing in this particular case,
we might call it identify and abstract, identify an abstract.
Bottom-up controller processing rather than top-down in the previous case.
We have just defined two other elements of our periodic table,
of our growing periodic table of intelligence. In this latter element,
the bottom-up classification, the conditions of application are different.